[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants
[Musique]
quel froid je suis gelé ce soir ce que
tu es frileux c'est un peu de
gymnastique ça te réchauffera
[Musique]
et c'est vrai qu'un peu de mouvement ça
réchauffe
bonsoir les enfants
on est bien ennuyé tu sais et pourquoi
de plus facile voyons d'abord le 1
puis le 2
la musique
voilà
[Musique]
allô allô
ici nounours
c'est trois pépites par le plus fort oui
par le plus fort on entend mal
comment ça va
pas bien de tout
méchant est malade
[Musique]
pour toi salut tu sais je suis malade
nous pauvre petit cornichon oh c'est
bien tu sais oh mon gars je suis dans le
lit de mes parents et je suis tout rouge
ce serait une rougeole que ça ne
m'étonnerait pas
c'est une rougeole c'est une rougeole oh
quelle voiture
mais non c'est Dada qui parlait ah bon
dodo aussi la rougeole non je n'ai pas
la rougeole je n'y comprends plus rien
en tout cas couvre-toi bien il faut
avoir très chaud je vais venir te voir
à bientôt au revoir
je vais aller voir ce petit cornichon
vous faites attention de ne pas attraper
la rougeole
j'ai déjà eu je crois oh moi j'aimerais
bien la voir en 4 un peu au lit on fait
un gâteau
qui dit des fois voilà voilà j'y vais on
te fâche pas
pourvu que je ne l'attrape pas moi la
rougeole
vous viendrez avec moi quand il sera
guéri et promettez-moi de bien vous
endormir tous les soirs pendant mon
absence
famille comme une ours embrasse-le pour
nous et puis t'as aussi
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit
au revoir nounours à bientôt
[Musique]
oh patron je me fais du souci
cornichon et malade et tu voudrais aller
le voir oui s'il vous plaît et bien en
route allons voir notre petit malade
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher et faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]